well after a very long year one local
business owner is hoping to spread a
little more positivity
reporter kate houston spoke to a
children's event planner who's now
expanding her business in the hopes of
inspiring the next generation of young
women
kate yes sasha sharice chapman has spent
years developing her business
creating custom birthday themes with all
of the personalized touches
now she's hoping to take it on the road
in the form of a mobile tea party
called the positivity bus i want to
be a positive influence i want to be an
example
sharice chapman is the owner of she's
creative which specializes in custom
themes and decor for children's events
after losing her god sister to gun
violence
and struggling with her own
self-confidence chapman wants to build
up and inspire the next generation of
young girls
having to kind of reconstruct myself
from the inside out
it i i want to pour back i feel like i'm
so
full of positivity i just want to pour
it back out into
these young girls to help in that effort
chapman is expanding her business to
include the positivity
bus my idea is to have it look like a
garden tea party
so it'll have florals and pinks and
golds and like
different seating will have little
tables where the
little ladies can enjoy their tea now
chapman is trying to raise 27 thousand
dollars on gofundme to transform this
recently purchased bus
it will need to be gutted then fitted
with custom seating
tvs dessert tables lighting audio and
decorations
every set of little girls young women
that step
out i want them to step into something
greater
then they they'll become the next i like
your shoes i like you're so pretty
where'd you get your shirt
the bus will be able to hold up to 10
kids at a time chapman plans to
incorporate fun
crafts with positive messages and words
of affirmation
the more it's seen the more it's
mimicked and
i think we're going to spark something
something big here and i want to see it
go as far as it can go
in addition to expanding her business
chapman would like to use this
opportunity as a way to provide jobs to
young people in the community
for a link to her gofundme you can head
to our website 8newsnow.com